hello everyone welcome to the mindscape
podcast i'm your host sean carroll
we live in a world where there's
increasing understanding of
and hopefully acceptance of different
varieties
of sexuality and gender orientation and
gender
expression not just the usual boy and
girl getting together getting married
having two and a half kids
we're increasingly happy with
homosexuality
with bisexuality hopefully transgender
people are being more and more accepted
as time goes on although we're certainly
not
there yet so what about asexuality
what about people who do not foreground
sexual desire
in their lives in the way that everybody
else does this is an idea that most of
us have heard of
but maybe are not too familiar with
asexuality
it turns out can span a wide variety of
manifestations from people who
are very romantic and even have
fulfilling sexual relationships with
their partners
to people who are completely repulsed by
the idea of having sex
and it's interesting not just to
understand those people
and their needs and how they can
flourish in this world
but how the rest of us when we're
telling stories
or organizing society more broadly take
for granted
the idea that whatever your sexual
orientation is sex is something that you
will want to have and it'll be a
success story when it's going well for
you so today's guest is angela
chen she is a science journalist and she
is asexual herself
or ace as they say in the business and
she's written a new book about this
called ace what asexuality reveals about
desire
society and the meaning of sex it's
interesting if nothing else just to
reflect
on the centrality of the idea of sex
in our lives and how we think about our
lives so
i like that just the idea that coining a
term
right adding some vocabulary to the way
that we conceptualize the world
changes the way we think about it in an
important way and asexuality is an
example of that but
i think the lessons here are broader so
let's go
angela chen welcome to the mindscape
podcast thank you so much for having me
so i think asexuality which we're going
to be talking about would you have a new
book coming out why don't you tell us
the name of your new book so that
everyone can go out and buy it
it's called ace what asexuality reveals
about desire society and the meaning of
sex
ace by the way congratulations on that i
mean it's a good label
for a sexuality or some sexual
preference i mean ace is a good word
right like
you did well in the label right i
actually prefer it
far more than i like the word asexual
which to me still sounds very clinical
yeah clinical or judgy or something like
that right yeah
so um i think this is one of those cases
where
the word asexual is probably something
where people hear it
and even if they've never been exposed
to it before they think they know what
it means
and from reading your book i know that
maybe you don't know maybe we don't know
what it means so
let's just start at the beginning and
you can explain to us a little bit about
what it means to be
asexual or ace absolutely i really think
that you know with all due respect to
the people
at the beginning who were building up
the asexual ace movement
i really think that there were some
issues of semantics here
because when you hear the word asexual
you think you know without sex but it's
actually a huge umbrella that
encompasses
so many people so many experiences
including people who have positive
sexual experiences
so i completely understand why people
would say things like
wait why would you call someone who does
have sex asexual that doesn't
make sense so all those to say i have a
lot of sympathy for all the confusion
around
the term so the usual definition
the official definition is someone who's
asexual they don't experience sexual
attraction
and that sounds simple enough i think
until you start thinking about all of
the things that we get confused with
sexual attraction
and all of the baggage around that term
i first came across the term asexual
when i was 14
and they came across the correct term
and immediately i was like oh
that's interesting glad to know that
there are people out there like this
my life i didn't think i was asexual and
i wouldn't
i wouldn't think about it again for
another 10 years and after i'd had two
romantic and sexual relationships well
yeah so i mean i think that from the
word
asexual it would it would clearly follow
it would seem to follow that you don't
have sex but one of the major lessons
right from the
part of the book is that there are
asexuals who do have sex
even who enjoy it but there is this
desire versus attraction dichotomy which
i thought was fascinating
right exactly so i think it's easy often
to
first explain asexuality in terms of
what it is not
so it doesn't mean not having sex we
have a word for that right that's
celibacy
it means not experiencing sexual
attraction
and i think a lot of people when they
think they don't experience sexual
attraction that means oh they're
disgusted by sex they're repulsed by sex
but that the tricky thing is that's not
the case either
i don't actually like using food
analogies but they're really convenient
so i'll have to use one here
if you'll excuse me so i think most of
us we have eight foods that we
like and that we crave and then we have
foods that we just
don't like and they don't taste good and
we would never eat them
and then there's just foods in the
middle where you don't really care so
much
for the particular pie or something but
because it's part of a routine it's
something your mother made every sunday
it has all of these
emotional social interactions you
you desire in that way and i think
that's the experience of a lot of people
who are asexual
where they don't feel sexual attraction
they don't crave um
sexual intimacy with other people for
physical reasons
but there might be emotional reasons and
social reasons they're bored or
they want to feel attractive and that's
kind of where all the nuances start to
come in
yeah and i get the impression that it's
part of the um
you know expanding our horizons a little
bit and understanding that there are
spectra
there are continuous versions of all
these different things is that
there are asexuals who are repulsed by
the idea of sex right and there are
others who are
into it when they're in love with
somebody and there are others who you
know like you say
don't really care one way or the other
but are willing to go along
right there is this huge spectrum of
experiences
and you know in the same way where
people who aren't asexual
who are called allosexual it's not like
people who are allosexual want sex
all the time either right it's never a
binary people's you know desires shift
so with asexuality there's this huge
range of
experiences and it can be so hard to
separate
you know the reasons why you might want
to have sex with someone is it just
physical quote-unquote just is it
emotional
is it boredom and that's where a lot of
the tricky parts
come in yeah you know i once wrote a
blog post
uh in one of my more daring moments uh
about the
the the gender tesseract where i said
like there's at least four different
dimensions on which we can talk about
you know uh people's biology people's
sexual
identity people's sexual attraction uh
and i i
realized i said at the time like i'm
sure i'm missing things
and i think that the amount of sexual
attraction was definitely something that
i'm missing so
but they're all independent right i mean
there are gay
asexuals and heteroasexuals exactly you
know there are people who are asexual
and like you said they're attracted to
the same gender or all genders
and you know sexual orientation i think
doesn't have to be the same as
romantic orientation that's one of the
distinctions that people who are asexual
make
you might not be sexually attracted to
anyone but you might still feel that
romantic attraction that crush that
emotional desire and that and that
is what we call romantic orientation and
is it something where
you know if so let's say you're a
straight ace
so you might be romantically attracted
to someone of the opposite gender
and then is it more likely you would
want to
be sexually involved with them also or
is that just up in the air
i think it can vary i think that if you
are if you're
if you're heteroromantic you're a
straight ace and you
are romantically involved with someone i
think that for some that can
increase you know your willingness or
your desire to have sex with them for
others you might be
a straight ace and you're sex repulsed
and that doesn't change at all
right whether you want to have sex with
someone or not
and i i again a lot of my questions are
going to be like i think what i
understood is this
am i right or am i wrong so the idea
that uh
what are the distinctions between being
ace and being aloe is allosexual is that
the opposite
yeah so is uh that that
for allosexuals there's just something
called or you know uh free-floating
sexual desire like you would like to
have sex and you know you're not sure
with who or you don't have any target
in mind and that's the kind of thing
that doesn't exist for aces
yeah i think i think that
it's all about having the target so we
people can have different libidos right
and that's not attached to sexual
orientation
you can be gay and have a high libido or
be gay and have a low libido
and you can be ace actually and have a
sex drive you can have that feeling
inside your body where you just desire
sexual release
but what's different is that aces don't
have that toward a person
you know sometimes you can be allosexual
and you can just
you know have feel sexually frustrated
and it's not toward a person
and i think most people have experienced
that but sometimes you can be allosexual
and it is prompted by a person or it's
caused by a person
whereas for aces even those who do have
a libido and not all aces have a libido
but for the ones who do
there's never a desire to get other
people involved
i think one person i spoke to described
as
not feeling any different than having an
itch on her arm you know there's an itch
on her arm
she'll she'll scratch it and just take
care of it herself why would she ask
someone to come over and scratch the
itch on her arm
you know it's just a different way of
thinking and experiencing the world
okay good i get it i i was actually
wrong so i'm glad that you clarified
that i mean
uh we're gonna get sort of the clinical
stuff out of the way first so people
uh know the ground that we're walking on
here i mean how well
is this understood the phenomenon of
being ace is this something that uh
psychologists and sexologists have been
studying for a long time
i don't think this is well understood
even now so
there is some clinical research on it
and i think the clinical research on it
is growing
but one problem is as we said the word
asexual is so broad
and therefore when you're doing research
if you pull in all these people from
that are all asexual but such different
experiences some are sex repulsed some
have sex
you know some have a sex drive some
don't then i think
that will really muddy up um your
results right and that will
have consequences for what we can know i
think another issue when it comes to
sexology is that for a long time
we just have this bias that everyone
naturally has
a sex drive experience of sexual
attraction and if you don't
then it means that it's some kind of
disability or there's something wrong
with you
or maybe you're a victim of sexual
assault
or trauma and because of that so much of
the research in this area has been gone
through that lens
instead of seeing it as just another
part of human variation
so that's one reason that it hasn't been
those are some reasons that it hasn't
been very well understood
i think it's been better understood when
it comes to looking at in a more
sociological sense rather than a medical
sense but even then
even though the orientation's been
around for 20 years in some ways it
really
flies under the radar still yeah no i
mean it absolutely does one of the
things this is skipping ahead a little
bit but
one of the things you talk about in the
book is the representation
of aces in fiction and popular culture
which
is basically almost nothing right there
isn't that much
absolutely usually when there are aces
they have a very specific stereotype you
know
for male aces um if they're not
explicitly ace it's usually a character
like sherlock holmes you know someone
who is
extremely um rational and he has better
things to worry about than sexuality
with women there's often these tropes of
you know people who are quirky and
that's why they're not interested in sex
so they're childish
and a lot of the representation in pop
culture it's on the fringes
it's not really it's not like major
literary fiction for example you'll see
it a lot in y
a or y a being young adult or you see it
a lot in science fiction
it's almost never discussed in what we
consider really mainstream or
almost prestigious um
forms of pop culture and while and i
think the effect that has on it is that
it can make the orientation itself seem
like it's on the fringes and seem like
it's something that's
for children or something that's you
know
not part of normal everyday life todd
chavez being the obvious
shining counter example here right on
bojack horseman yeah todd chavez
and the thing is i know that the uh
showrunners for bojack horseman actually
reached out to someone who was part of
an ace group in los angeles
and they asked her to consult and ask
her some questions about asexuality
so they definitely were trying to do
their due diligence and todd has
done so much for the ace community
because of todd
because of explaining and debunking some
of these misconceptions there are
more ace people in the world i know
someone who
discovered that she was asexual because
she actually was writing an article
about how the asexual community reacted
to todd it's actually very meta you know
in the case of writing this article she
realized oh
i didn't think asexuality meant this but
this applies to me
but even with todd you know he's kind of
like a hapless childish character he's
literally a cartoon
uh it's still a little bit you know on
the edges of culture
did but you didn't mention zonker harris
from doonsbury would he qualify
i am not familiar with that i have to
say i'm not the best at
um i'm not i i just i'm not familiar
with that
yeah i mean i thought of it only after
you know reading your book and
zonker so if you're not familiar with
doonesbury zonker's been a character
who's been around since the 70s
and uh while everyone like you know the
the dunesbury cast has sort of grown up
slightly and
have relationships and everyone else is
sleeping around and everything
he never has and i think in more recent
years like
it's become a topic and people you know
have asked him about and he's like i
don't believe there's any such thing as
sex i think it's just a myth you people
are
joking about to me but he's a bit of a
you know sort of otherworldly character
anyway
and he didn't he's never been explicitly
labeled like that in the comic
yeah that's really interesting because
there's a lot of discussion about the
importance
of explicitly labeling characters you
know oftentimes if you want to make a
character that's gay you don't have to
have them say i'm gay right you can just
show them
with you know as someone of the same
gender but with asexuality
if someone is single then most of the
time you just assume
they're allosexual and just happen to be
single but i think in the case you just
mentioned because he says
he makes these comments about asexuality
i think that's
one way would you just explicitly have
to say it but that's still
not the cross it might be at least from
what you've just said
no it does sound like it i mean i wonder
i'm not sure how much credit to give to
gary trudeau
the cartoonist but i mean maybe he he
knew people
like that or or something or maybe it
was just an accident and he just never
came up with a good story line you know
that's
the the intent of the author is always
hard to figure out but
i also do want to get on the table you
tell this wonderful horrible story about
the infamous house
episode uh which is probably a more
typical representation of asexuality on
tv
right absolutely so in the episode there
is a woman who says that she's asexual
and then one of the characters says this
to house and house says something like
she's definitely not asexual you know
plenty of people don't have sex
but the only people who don't want sex
are sick lying or dead
and the entire storyline is just him
well one of the side story lines is him
trying to figure out whether there's a
medical reason for her lack of interest
in sex
and this of course being the show house
there is
so she's not asexual she's pretending to
be asexual
because her husband is asexual and she
wants to be with him
but then the other twist is that her
husband isn't even asexual
he apparently has some kind of brain
tumor that can be easily fixed
and once they fix that then they're just
going to be two happy aloe people
i think to this day um and definitely
before
pod chavez on bojack that was probably
the most
mainstream high profile depiction of
asexuality
in which house someone who's supposed to
be really smart and
knows everything and sees through the
stuff that no one else can see through
is essentially declaring that
asexual people are sick lying or dead
and he's right at least in the context
of the episode
did they actually i never saw that
episode in particular i've seen other
episodes but did they
use the word asexual or did they just
talk about the impossibility of people
not wanting to have sex
they used the word asexual at the very
beginning the woman
is i'm sorry at the very beginning i
think they're talking about birth
control or something
and then one of the doctors says you
know every method is available and then
she says i'm asexual and she even goes
into this little wheel saying you know
it's not celibacy it's our orientation
so it's very explicitly about
asexuality not just low sexual desire or
not when you have sex
i mean i i asked that because one of the
points that came across from your book
and i
so as a non-asexual myself but someone
who was just fascinated uh
i had a lot of philosophical resonance
with your book because
a lot of it is about the right way to
categorize
things in the world right and you make
the point that just the existence of the
word
asexual the fact that there is a
category suddenly like can
you know set off uh bells of recognition
in your brain it's like
it made me think of uh when susan came
out
kane came out with that book on
introverts and suddenly people could say
oh it's not just that i'm a weirdo who
doesn't want to go to parties every
night i'm an introvert i have a label
now i'm okay absolutely i think in many
ways a lot of my
book is about language and the ways in
which
we don't talk on a specific enough level
so
early in the book i talk about my own
experience and
growing up i didn't fit this mold of
what it looked like to be asexual i was
not repulsed by sex it seemed very
interesting to me
as a teenager you know i would talk
about crushes with my friends
there even to myself that there didn't
seem to be anything different
and it was only much later that i
realized that we were using the same
words
but we meant different things you know
when they said oh
he's hot they were feel i think they
were experiencing something sexual they
were feeling that physical pull
and i would just mean oh i would say oh
he's hot you know i had prophetic
preferences
but it wouldn't be it wouldn't feel
physical but
we don't talk like that we don't get to
the nitty-gritty there's so many
generalities
and so it can be so hard to figure out
exactly what your experience is
and how it can be different from other
people but yeah with the word asexual i
think once you know the word
then you know how to search for it and
that's where it leads you to all these
resources it's a lot like a lot of
experience i have with science
journalists
where you'll be looking for the name of
the discipline you'll be like oh i know
there's
something that's kind of like chemistry
and kind of like physics
and then once you realize oh it's
material science you know there's an
entire field like that
then that's when you learn so much and
you know where to go and who to talk to
but before that you're just googling
things like
what is something that is like this
chemistry like physics you know
right yeah it can be very hard if you
don't have that that vocabulary and it's
related
you just brought up another you know
closely related thing which is the idea
that
you don't necessarily appreciate that
other people
are seeing and thinking about the world
in a very different way it made me think
about
do you know about uh aphantasia yeah
it's funny you mentioned that because an
earlier draft of the book
actually used that exact analogy oh good
so explain to us the analogy
it's great i think right so i use the
example um
so at one point there was some engineer
who wrote this
viral facebook post about aphantasia and
he was talking about he was 30 years old
and had just discovered that other
people can see images
in their mind but he couldn't and you
would say you know
when people would say imagine a beach he
would think about the idea of a beach
he didn't realize that other people were
actually seeing
images in their head and what's funny is
i actually have a very weak visual
imagination myself so this
hit home in many ways and yeah so
there is that philosophical aspect to it
like what i said
you know what other people are saying um
sexy or hot what do they mean how would
you know that they don't mean what you
mean if there's not glaring differences
you know the way we use language it's
shared it's so hard to know
what's the same and what's different
yeah the fact that you know you could
have i mean there were even um visual
artists
who have advantage and like they they
never realized that people were not
being metaphorical when they said you
know visualize an apple or or
something like that and our culture is
just
uh you know besotted with the language
of sexuality and desire and lust and
libido and
uh i don't know you tell me but growing
up ace does that
was that something that you you thought
you did appreciate and didn't realize
until later like they were talking about
something different
yeah absolutely like i said there was no
indication at all that
my experience was different in any way
and if anything as a kid you know i was
kind of cheeky i had kind of a raunchy
sense of humor
and this reminded me of the story of a
woman that i interviewed
and she grew up pretty religious in a
small town in oklahoma
and she and her friends were atheists
from a young age
and they would go to church and you know
they would sit there and
do whatever but you know they would kind
of look at each other and build their
eyes you know like
we're performing this but no one really
believes in this and then later
it was the same for her with sexuality
where
you know people would say oh he's so hot
and then she would play along and she'd
be the first person to make a joke about
like a naked greek statue that they
learned about history class you know but
for her she always thought it was the
same thing she was like oh we're just
performing this
but no one really cares and then she
said that once you know her best friend
i think when they were 16
had sex for the first time and they were
talking about it and this woman was like
oh was it horrible um did it traumatize
you and her friend was like no no
um it was good or mediocre at least you
know it wasn't traumatized
your first time right right and it was
the first time she realized that
she had thought that everyone was in on
the joke but everyone else actually
experienced
um sex being a big deal yeah no i mean
it's it's amazing so to go back to the
clinical side of things you know
that house episode um reminds us that
we have a long history of classifying
deviations from the norm
as mental disorders or somehow uh
disabilities and
and i forget is is asexuality
essentially still
in the dsm is something that we would
try to treat and cure
it is you know the dsm seems to change
quite a bit
but the um but the diagnosis that
most closely matches is hypoactive
sexual desire disorder
though it's in the latest version it's
been split up into male and female forms
and essentially some of the criteria
sound just like asexuality
it's not it's you know lack of sexual
interest
lack of sexual fantasies it basically it
really
there you know there's nitty-gritty
stuff but in general it lines up and so
you can make a very strong argument
that asexuality is in the dsm the funny
thing is that
in in the late 2000s a task group
recommended that there be an exception
that you couldn't be diagnosed or
shouldn't be diagnosed
with this disorder if you identified as
asexual and i think that was an
interesting
move toward acknowledging sexual
variation but
to me it still seems kind of
philosophically confused
well exactly i mean it raises questions
that honestly i think
are difficult to answer at least for me
i mean uh
there are such things as mental
disorders
but we have this history of classifying
like i said all sorts of just
deviations from accepted behavior uh
even if they're completely harmless
you know obviously being gay for a long
time uh was in
that classification and so how should we
decide like when people are perfectly
fine and living their lives and
and everything is okay versus when we
should treat them and try to fix them in
some way
i feel like these ideas should be
separated
so the reason that i thought the asexual
exception doesn't make sense
is because to me it's like saying that
if you identify
as homosexual then you're fine but if
you happen to experience
same gender same-sex attraction then you
have a disorder you know it seems like
this weird semantic thing
to me i think that it's i think that
it's fine
to have low to have low sexual desire
not experience sexual attraction that's
not a deviation
and i think that in many cases if you're
that even if it's fine
maybe it's okay to change it maybe it's
okay to want
to um enhance it for your relationship
or for or for very
various reasons i'm a really big
believer in bodily autonomy
and i i'm not necessarily against
diagnosis
but i think in this case when there's
been a long history of pharmaceutical
companies trying to sell
you know libido boosting drugs most of
them not successful
when the language is so stigmatized when
it's presented in a way that seems like
you have to fix it like it's the
subjective fact that there's something
wrong
i think that should be i think that
should be addressed
and i mean like like you say we we're in
a culture
that valorizes sex a lot i mean
at the same time as we're slightly uh
titillated and made uncomfortable by
talking about it
the there's it's clear that the default
is to think that
wanting sex is good having sex is good
being
uh good at sex is good you know and
having a high sex drive is good and
where does that come from right and you
know are we is one of the lessons of the
ace movement
that that was just a sort of mistake all
along to to think that way and we should
be more open
i think the situation is complicated
everything you described exists
but it also exists alongside you know
slut-shaming and
sexual repression is real and you know
people's sexualities are controlled so
these things exist in different pockets
they exist in the same pocket
obviously i'm not trying to deny that
purity culture also exists
i think there's a lot of different um
causes of this kind of culture
i think evolutionary psychology in a way
is like people often say oh you know we
evolved
to have sex it's so natural even though
i don't personally find that a very
compelling reason to do something just
because
we might have evolved to do it but
people do say that as one reason
another reason is simply i think sex is
titillating
and sex sells and you know there's so
many ad campaigns around the idea of sex
equals vitality and so it compounds and
it's all around us with the ace movement
i don't think
aces are interested in desexualizing
everything aces
obviously don't hate people who have sex
we're fine with that it's more it's more
the idea that
there is a there's a real imbalance
and i at least for speaking for me i
think the answer is just
more messages of different kinds you
know i don't want to stop people from
talking about how much they love sex
but it's so skewed can we have more
messages from the other side
can we have more representation in
fiction and pop culture
so multiplicity of messages i think so
it's not in many ways i don't think it's
a mistake that
um society is sexualized i think for
many people it's joyful
it's just there needs to be more than
one way yeah
i mean it made me think in some ways in
the on the philosophy side of things of
a podcast interview i did with lori paul
about transformative experiences and her
idea was
you know you try to be rational about
choices you make but some of those
choices will actually
turn you into a different person whose
preferences are different
and she likes to use the example of
being a vampire you know you
you might not want to be a vampire but
once you're bitten and turn to a vampire
you like it
but it's clearly a metaphor for things
like having children or going to
graduate school or something like that
but and she doesn't have any easy
answers but but the point is so if
you're someone who doesn't have sexual
desire
um that's one thing and then there's
another thing is
do you want to have sexual desire like
are you do you want it because you you
think that that would be good and it's
like learning a new musical instrument
or do you want it just because society
is telling you that you should want it
absolutely and i think that's something
that
almost all ace people struggle with at
some point especially at the beginning
of realizing they're asexual
and you know i think this comes up a lot
in discussion about libido booth and
drugs you know is it
a violation or betrayal of who you are
if you take those
um is that will that mean that you are
giving in to the societal pressure that
definitely exists
and the answer i i mean i don't have a
perfect answer i think it's
i think it's very i think it's very
complicated and i think the only thing
that people can do
is first of all you know on a macro
level try to
try to release some of the massive
pressure to be more sexual but then on a
personal level you know you make your
own decisions for some people maybe
their orientation is not that
important to them and their relationship
is more important to them for example
for other people maybe they think oh
this is
this is a part of who i am this is my
identity i don't want to
change that and that's totally fine too
i think people should be able to
make their own decisions especially even
though we are
all not all but even though most aces
are disadvantaged by
these societal pressures i mentioned
yeah i mean on the one hand i'm very
much in favor of people making their own
decisions on the other hand we all know
people are terrible at making their own
decisions but
i can't think of any better system than
letting them do it neither can i you
know and i think there's so many
parallels
many years ago i wrote this piece for
aeon the magazine and it was about
anti-love drugs and it kind of touched
on similar topics and one thing i
pointed out was
you know for example women who get
breast implants
oftentimes that's because of
these really narrow beauty societal
standards that i think we should all get
rid of right
like i don't think i think it's a good
thing to get rid of saddle standards at
the same time
i think it would feel weird to ban women
from being able to get breast implants
you know i don't think it's a perfect
analogy but i think some of the same
questions
are are there and it's not an easy
question to answer
do we have any idea of how many people
are ace it's complicated the number that
is thrown around all the time is one
percent and it's based on
a survey from uh more than a decade ago
by now
but like i said because there's so many
confusions about what it means to be ace
i think the number honesty is much
higher you know earlier in life
i would never have put asexual as my
sexual orientation
on a form in many places that is not
even available
you know as a sexual orientation on many
forms many people don't know what it
means so how can you know whether that's
you or not
right but and is it just trying to get
the nomenclature right
is it an orientation is that right
because it's different than being
gay or straight it is a sexual it is a
sexual orientation
okay um can it be temporary
can like people go through phases of
being asexual and then
come back or is it something that we
should think of as more deeply rooted
and whether your libido comes and goes
is a different thing
that's an interesting question and i
think one that
is still being discussed and not just
with asexuality but with many sexual
orientations
you know i think most people think of
sexual orientations whether it's
being gay or being straight or being
sexual as
this deep thing in which it's who you
are and how you've always been
who you are deep down whereas i
personally think it's much better to
think about
sexualities in a much more fluid way you
know if someone
is is gay and then later there with
someone of the opposite gender i don't
think that means they were
they were never gay or that you know
that period of their lives was fake
somehow
i think people go in and out of
different sexualities throughout their
life
for the purposes of research i think
many people used to have this
requirement that asexuality was lifelong
but it wasn't caused by anything else
that was not related to disability
or or sexual trauma but i think that
it's
actually more helpful to think of it as
a fluid thing and that people can go
through periods of being more and less
asexual
and again on a more macro level i think
it's pretty clear as people
grow older you know they're more likely
to go through phases of being
yeah yeah sure and it it does raise once
again this
difficult philosophy problem having to
do with identity right i mean on the one
hand we want to say
um our identities are important they
shape who we are how society looks at us
and things like that on the other hand
we want to say
and i should be free to change it and
still be
someone who i am and so i i think that
uh you know in many ways
tell me what you think but i think that
in many ways you know society is
becoming gradually more comfortable
with both acknowledging identity and
letting it be a little bit more slippery
than it would have been in a more rigid
past
i hope so i think that in many ways and
i think it's just me speaking for myself
asexuality developed as a response
to all of these societal pressures to be
sexual what i call compulsory sexuality
if these pressures didn't exist um then
i think there would be much less need
for people to find community to
have this sense of shared culture to use
the asexual label
so i personally think my dream is that
one day we don't have the dsm
entry that corresponds asexuality but we
also don't need asexuality
as an identity because it'll you can
just say whatever you want and you don't
you won't people won't doubt you and
people you won't need to this community
to validate
your choices because you won't be so
much on the fringes so i hope
society is moving in that way and i
think i think that's the way
i'd like society to move in i guess
another thing to be clear about is there
would be a difference between
being fully and happily and
self-actualized as a
as an ace versus just having your
sexuality repressed away
right i mean both of those things are
possible i take it but they're different
things
yeah absolutely and i think this is
something that comes up a lot when we're
talking about
gender specifically with with women you
know of course
there's this trope of the sexually
repressed sexually conservative woman
who
has been shamed into being repressed and
i think that happens for a lot of people
and i think that's a shame
i also think that sometimes people who
are sexually conservative it's not
because they're repressed it's just
because that's
that's how they are and so it's
important to acknowledge that both exist
and that both people might need
different things now we can just be
respectful of what each might need
i mean maybe it's time to move into you
know more having the clinical stuff out
of the way we can be a little bit more
personal about it i mean
what is it like either from your
perspective or from the many people who
you interviewed for your book i mean
what is it like to discover
that this is an identity that you have
and to sort of
wonder what you're supposed to do next
when in a society that is just not built
for you
it's really different there's one person
i interviewed who really fits the mold
of how the media portrays asexuality
meaning they felt from
an early age that they were different
they hated the idea of sex
they were freaked out by it and then one
day they discovered asexuality from a
dear abby column
and they said you know immediately this
word made sense
oh there's other people like me out
there oh i don't have to have sex one
day if i don't want to even though
people are always telling me that i'm
going to want it and
that i'm going to become a different
person and so there are people like that
who really embrace it because it
shows them that the way that they felt
different isn't
bad it is something to be ashamed of but
there's other people like them out there
and they can find support
there's also people and i think i
personally fall more into this category
where it just brings up a lot more
ambivalence
and you know ever since i have been
promoting the book and i published an
excerpt people have been reaching out to
me and saying
oh i've never seen asexuality described
the way that you described it even
though i knew about
the term in the orientation i'm thinking
whether i might be asexual
and i have so many complicated
ambivalent feelings about it on the one
hand i think
it's a relief because there's a feeling
of recognition you know that oh yeah
these things they thought that might be
weird
that's still there but on the other hand
you know if you didn't feel
that strange or different growing up
which i didn't
then you i think you can get saddled
down the baggage
you know one minute you're just an aloe
person
who maybe has some right string quote
unquote experience of sex
the next the next minute you have to
think oh is this the whole identity
and there's all of these perceptions
about what it means to be asexual like
we talked about the word
it's associated with being you know
prude are you a prude
are you repressed are you not vital
because
you know you live a sexless or possibly
sexless life
it can bring a lot of baggage and a lot
of complications too
yeah i mean but i i like the fact that
it's uh or that you bring
like the fact that you're bringing up
the fact that it might be different than
coming out
as gay or something like that or trans
where there there may have been
much more strongly all along some
feeling that you didn't fit into the
category you were supposed to
whereas being ace can kind of creep up
on you you can
you know you can have a raunchy sense of
humor and feel everything is okay and
it's suddenly like there's a whole new
conceptual world that opens up
absolutely and i think it's interesting
because the question of coming out can
be different
too for aces i think that
it often can feel unnecessary sometimes
you know not for everyone of course
but when you tell your parents for
example that you're asexual it does
feel it it does feel inappropriate
almost
i think in a way that's not true because
you know when you talk about sexual
attraction i think it feels like it's
talking about your sex life in this like
very direct
way and so i've talked to people who say
you know i feel strange
about coming out i don't think i i or i
didn't you know if they might be gay for
example
i didn't feel weird about coming out as
gay but i work in a conservative place
and it
really does feel like i'm trying to talk
to my co-workers about
my sex life in a way that's not true for
you know
other orientations so there's these
strange nuances there
and uh another thing just to let people
know i mean it's perfectly possible
for an ace to be in a loving romantic
relationship with an allosexual person
but
maybe there are you know there's there
are difficulties there but you know
there are difficulties in all
relationships so it's the kind of thing
you got to learn to work at work through
absolutely of course there's
difficulties there and
one thing that i think about is that as
you mentioned there are serious
difficulties in every relationship you
know
money kids who can take care of the
parents
that kind of thing but sexual
difficulties really have
a stigma around them almost you know i
feel like
many people feel comfortable um talking
to
friends about money troubles or you know
how we're gonna raise the kids but there
seems to be something
pathetic and sad about having sexual
difficulties or a sexual mismatch
even though that is so common and it's
i think very rare for two people to have
the exact same level of
libido forever so there i think
oftentimes
sexual compatibility is framed
differently
where i think many people are taught to
expect you know
you're going to have differences of
opinion when it comes to homes
and parents but there's not these
conversations about is it okay
to have sexual compatibility if other
things are more important
or is that settling you know there's a
shame around that
but so in your research have you found a
lot of successful examples of
relationships between aces and ellos
i think it depends on what you mean by
successful i mean i suppose the i
suppose the short answer is yes like i
don't think these people are any
less happy than allo couples i think it
can be much harder honestly for
aces to be in relationships with aloes i
think there can be a lot of
pressure and i think especially for
people who
at one point didn't know that they were
asexual and
so there was a lot of pressure you know
you're the low desired partner why do
you have this problem
why won't you fix it it's your
responsibility to fix it there was a lot
of that kind
of um dynamic in the relationship which
i think isn't fair
because you know the incompatibility is
from both people if both people had the
exact same level of desire whether it
was high or low it wouldn't be a problem
so therefore it should be a shared
problem you know with shared
responsibility
instead of it all going on the lower
desired partner and so especially for
people who didn't realize for a long
time
there was this feeling of frustration
and guilt and shame and
people can still have that even after
they realize that their ace
so i have found a lot of examples i
think
everyone that i found has really had to
become very good at talking to people
about difficult subjects
which in the end is a good life skill
for any long-term relationship that's
true and we can imagine various
strategies and compromises that such
couples uh might want to choose to
pursue but so
i take it that it's at least easier to
imagine
aces just being aces who are interested
in romantic entanglements to find them
with other aces
it is in theory i think in pra and
it is in theory and there are some ace
dating websites out there
i think in practice as anyone knows
sexual orientation
is not the most important factor in
compatibility and
most aces i know actually tr do try
to date aloes and see if there's a way
to make that work
oh that's interesting i mean is there is
that
just because there are more of them or
is there something about
you know that they actually find
attractive i think it's mostly because
there's just more of them i think there
really aren't that many aces out there
and so you're
and not only that but we don't you know
aces are all spread out right so it's
not like we have
we all live in the same place or you
know it's not like we have geographical
enclaves
and because of that i think it's just
you're surrounded by aloes in many ways
you sometimes just don't have a choice
and
i mean are there aces who don't even
want to just
have a partner relationship at all i
mean they're just uh
introverted and perfectly solitary and
also perfectly happy even though society
is going to be judging them
all along yeah there are and this is
something that's separate but related
so these people are called um romantic
you know
so you can be heteroromantic or
bi-romantic we talked about the sexual
orientation or you can be aromantic
and not all aces are a-remarkable
obviously many want and have romantic
relationships
and actually not all people who are
aromantic are
asexual either it was interesting i i
interviewed for the book someone a man
who is aromantic but he's not asexual
and there was a whole lot of baggage
that came with that too
especially because of his gender so yeah
um yeah they thought he was just being
an operator but he actually
uh we should if we're being accepting of
other
uh ways of living other modes it's
perfectly possible someone can enjoy
and like having sex in a perfectly good
faith good-natured
friendly way but just not be interested
in a partnered romantic relationship
exactly and he said that that's what he
wanted to do and he really cared about
his partners but he just
was not interested in romance but
because of all these ideas that only
sociopaths and serial killers
are interested in romance you know that
if you're not interested in romance you
just can't love or have no morality
i think that caused a lot of pain for
him you mentioned the idea of a boston
marriage which i'd never heard of before
but apparently comes from henry james
and yeah i think that you
i might be misremembering but i seem to
think either you or one of the people
you
interviewed said like we should bring
back the institution of the boston
marriage
right so that was the one that i
interviewed and a boston marriage is
essentially
these devoted partnerships of women
um living together and it comes from a
henry james novel and
some of these women i think were lesbian
but not all of them
and so one of the people i interviewed
did say that that's what you wanted
because this
woman was aromantic and she had a lot of
fears about what was going to happen to
her for
the rest of her life because if you're
aromantic then people always ask you
oh who's going to take care of you when
you're old you know what if you're all
alone
and in practice this often can be what
happens you know
her best friend who she's lived with for
years had moved out to live with her
boyfriend
and other of her friends were getting
married and she was having this
realization that
i'm a romantic i'm not going to be the
one who's going out to live
with a partner but my friends are all
going to partner up and
it felt like she was being left behind
and so she really wanted to see
the normalization of many different
types of partnerships and friendships
and that were devoted and that were
treated with just as much
respect and a sense of permanence as we
treat
romantic relationships i think that
there are
it seems to me a lot of depictions in
fiction of
couples especially older you know two
women living together
um and very often as basically
you know functioning as partners
although not romantic partners and the
implication either explicitly from the
author or
inferred by the audience is well they're
really lesbians they just don't want to
say so right but
this is another mode again that you
could be in like they could actually be
friends and partners in the
old-fashioned sense of the word partners
like managing the house and the finances
and so forth
without that romantic attachment right
and i think what a lot of people say is
that and they can feel
just as strongly toward each other and
be just as devoted toward each other
even if it's not romantic you know it
doesn't mean that it's not that
friendship is automatically less devoted
than
romance so there are many different
factors that conspire to make it so
i mean you mentioned the you know that
aces are thin on the ground and
therefore it can be hard to find a
like-minded partner it has the
uh and you also said that the the idea
of the orientation sort of is 20 years
old which is obviously very very young
has the internet and uh you know social
media
communities played a huge role in this
uh
self-recognition absolutely so
aces have existed or rather people who
we today would describe as asexual have
existed for a long time you know people
will say tesla
was maybe ace or andy warhol was
possibly ace
but before the internet i think it was
just hard for
like-minded people to get together on
the mass scale so it was really in the
early 2000s
that people started finding these
communities and discussing their lives
and
you know even describing what asexuality
meant you know asexuality
didn't have to mean quote a person who
doesn't experience sexual attraction
that's a definition that people made up
and agreed on
and it could have been another way you
know maybe if things have gone
differently
i would say that i'm non-sexual and my
book would have a different title
that would be confusing because you know
celibate is not the same but
yeah the internet has really had a huge
effect and it's been both good and bad
on the one hand it's facilitated a lot
of
base activism connecting people to each
other you know the usual
good parts of the internet on the other
hand because of the history of
asexuality and because of
how new relatively asexual activism
still is
it's often you know derided as an
internet orientation
for people on tumblr and i think that in
many ways
makes it seem less accessible or less
legitimate which is a shame because
they're
i'm sure many people who are not on
tumblr and not
very online who would benefit from
learning more about asexuality and how
aces view the world
i mean the the birth of a new social
movement large or small is uh
um i mean it's kind of like childbirth
right i mean it's a beautiful miracle
but it's also very messy and painful
are there uh huge ongoing controversies
within the community that are roiling
uh people's emotions and very dramatic
or is it more or less
a successful story of people coming
together and going ah yes we found each
other
i think any community will always have
on ongoing discussions
i think in the earlier years of the
community there was a lot of gatekeeping
there's still gatekeeping but
particularly in earlier years there's a
lot of discussion
that if you're disabled you can't be
asexual because the idea was
people already thought that asexuality
was related to some kind of medical
illness you know
and people were trying so hard to fight
that impression and so it felt like
you know getting as far away from
anything that could taint that
um was good and the same for survivors
of sexual assault
um there was idea that oh if you were
sexually assaulted then
obviously that caused it you can't be
asexual and i don't think that did the
community any services
because it just cut people off and
it it was not inclusive and i don't
think it was healthy
and nowadays you know there's many even
within the spectrum
there's a lot of gelatin about what
makes you ace enough
i think there's actually a lot of
discussion within the larger queer
community about the extent to which
you are queer if you are asexual and
straight
and i think that you are but i think
that's not entirely a settled question
people do like their gatekeeping i mean
that's that's much more universal than
sexual desire
there are no a gatekeepers out there in
in the world um i mean
so from the experience of this movement
is there
are there lessons or advice for the rest
of the world
um you know i think i mean probably most
kind-hearted people once they hear that
there are people who are
asexual will be favorably disposed to
them but are they like are there common
mistakes that people make in uh
in talking to aces that we could do
better to avoid
i think um in in terms of just
talking to aces you know obviously don't
say things like
oh you haven't found the right person or
oh should you go to the doctor you know
anything that
sounds like you think that asexuality
isn't real that's pretty basic
but in terms of you know lessons for the
rest of the world i think there are a
lot
you know i think a weakness of many
people broadly is that people think that
a community doesn't have lessons for
them if they're not part of the
community but even if you're not asexual
i think really questioning what exactly
is sexuality
um what is sexual attraction because
it's actually extremely hard to define
and one of the funny things is being an
asexual person
you know you always feel like you have
to your identity is based on not
experiencing something
but because you don't experience that
thing then it's hard for you to say what
you don't experience you know that's
another kind of quirk of language that
comes up with this whole topic
but i think it's good for everyone to
think closely you know what is the
difference between
um being aesthetically attracted to
someone and being sexually attracted to
someone
or being emotionally attracted to
someone i think there's a lot of things
to think about regarding
consent in relationships and these on
these invisible inequalities regarding
like we talked about earlier how the
lower desired partner is the one who
is supposed to do all the work and quote
fix themselves so
and there's a lot to think about
regarding the ways in which we prove
romantic relationships and often you
know often at the expense
of platonic relationships and so just to
be super duper clear you know there's no
problem being an ace and
looking at somebody and going oh my
goodness that person's very hot
no there's no there's no problem very
good
uh but i mean this is why i i the
philosophical implications were
fascinating to me because
it becomes clear that you know we have
this tendency to
package uh characteristics or identities
right and there's this ideal of
love and romance that goes along with
not just sexual desire but also
friendship and sharing the household and
things like that but
in principle these are all different and
you know figuring out exactly how to
divide up
uh the different ways and acknowledging
that in principle any of them could be
perfectly fine
is a little bit of philosophical uh
spade work we all have to do
exactly and sex and desire are simply so
symbolic
you know thinking about for example
books for children
sexuality is usually introduced as a way
to signal
that you are no longer a child you know
this is how you
pass the gate and you are no longer
innocent and now you can sit at the
adults table
and what child doesn't want to not be
you know to not be a child and to know
what everyone else knows
you know sexuality is when you are
chosen and loved
by someone other than your parents you
know for who you are
um if you want those things of course
and most people do
then how do you know whether you want to
be an adult
or you actually just want sex you know
basically i think
the big big lesson of the book and of
asexuality is that sex is coupled with
so many things
and it doesn't have to be so and you can
decouple them but it'll take a lot of
work
but i think all of us will be able to
learn something from interrogating that
more closely
well you use the phrase compulsory sex
sexuality and uh especially in regards
to
stories and and culture and novels and
films and
stuff like that the idea that you know
if you're telling a story there has to
be a
romantic sexual component to it
absolutely and at one point i write
about my attempt to find
a story again that's not why or science
fiction or something like that
in which there wasn't a major romantic
plot point in which you know
love or the pursuit of romantic love or
the pursuit of it or dating
wasn't part of it and i did find
examples of that but all of those
were exact all of those were of a
different genre so they might be
literary but they were holocaust novels
or they were war novels or they were
about rehabilitation they weren't just
what you typically call you know a
general literary fiction novel
the i you know compulsory sexuality and
the same with romance
is so embedded that many of us don't
notice it at all
and i think that limits the way we think
about the possibilities you know like do
i really want
romance and sex or do i just want to
feel some excitement
yeah no i when i was reading that
section of your book i thought well you
know well what about mystery novels like
there are mystery novels where there's
not any uh relationship uh
front and center but then then i got to
the point where you say like yes the
exceptions are all
in other labeled genres right and
i always wondered what qualified uh
a story as a genre story and maybe the
answer is
genre stories are stories that do not
foreground sexuality
in some way that's funny i never thought
about it that way and you know the
question of genre is this
big question that i don't necessarily
feel um qualified to answer
i mean intuitively we know it's like
crime fiction horror fiction
yeah but maybe that you can flip it
around and it's something that
it's a story that grounds something
besides love
and kind of like a middle-class life
yeah
yeah something like that like the the
package i mean that's the idea that we
have this set of expectations and
they're the norm against with we
against which we judge everything else
right and
i mean i take it that this is part of
what you hope happens is that there's
more variety more diversity of
experiences reflected
in our stories in our pop culture i
think so
and i think that there are many people
who find it easy to fit into
expectations of romance and sex and it's
easy to feel as natural but just because
it's easy doesn't mean it's actually
optimal for them and so i think that
branching out
would be helpful even if you haven't
felt like you were strange or
marginalized or different yeah i mean
the the
i'm also interested in this this idea of
representation and role models uh
because as a scientist
you know most of my uh colleagues
are men clearly uh mostly white some
asians right
very few african-americans or anything
like that very few gay people although
there are some
um and the idea that when we think of
what a scientist is we have a certain
view in mind
there's this famous study not really
study but thing that was done where they
asked some children to draw a scientist
and they all look like einstein
and they took him on a field trip to
fermilab and they met the physicist and
afterward they asked him to draw a
scientist and they wrote this diverse
crowd
it could really change people's lives
especially young people to see
people like them out there either on the
tv screen or the movie screen or
represented in the pages of a book
absolutely and i think it was powerful
for me too though i am far from being a
child
you know when i was first writing the
book and even now you know
i have ambivalent feelings about being
ace and i think that's
you know part and parcel of any kind of
identity especially one that's
lesser known but as i reported the book
and i met people
who were both aced and unburdened
by the things that bothered me it it
helped me
you know i met people who were ace and
they just didn't care
if other people might think that they
were prude or boring or lacking in
vitality or any of those
um circumstances they just said oh well
i've always been different
this was just another way i was
different and i didn't really think
about it
and for me who tends to be a little
self-conscious and worries about what
other people think
even having that kind of you know very
specific representation someone i was
interviewing
made a difference yeah and it's it is
going to be difficult
because i mean you make i i guess you
make this point subtextually when you're
talking about todd chavez in
about jack horseman and you mentioned
that the episode in which he is sort of
is most centered on him being asexual is
not the funniest or most dramatically
interesting one because it has to
function as a
pedagogical documentary as well as a
comedy cartoon show right he's like
explaining very earnestly what it means
and that's going to make it hard
in the early days to tell the compelling
stories that we hope will eventually
come
right and there's a lot of issues with
this anytime i think you want to have
um asexuality represented so you know
books and representation sits in a
vacuum so if you have someone who
for example is disabled and asexual and
you explicitly label them as asexual
if people don't bother to learn more
about the umbrella of asexuality i think
they'll just assume that disabled people
all disabled people
are intellectual or vice versa right
it's very hard to have representation
both because you have to know the
pedagogy but because
you you don't know how much you can
trust because it's not quite in the
culture yet
and there are also as you bring out in
the book all sorts of issues about
intersectional uh identity issues where
it matters whether you're you know black
or asian or white
or gay or straight or trans or cis or
whatever like
that's a over and above whether you're
ace or aloe that's going to come into
the mix of defining who you are and what
stories you're
going to want told about yourself yeah i
think being ace
because there's this assumption that
everyone is sexual and that's you know
what
gives us our lifeblood um i think
everyone is always questioning
oh am i actually sexual or have i am i
was shy
you know i'm actually sexual or am i
scared of the people that i
conceivably could be interested in but
if you are
um not white or if you are not a cis
then there's all these
um other questions of identity um
related to that
i interviewed a woman who is black and
asexual
and i should mention that the asexual
community is
fairly white and she said that you know
she started thinking she was asexual
and then she went and saw that everyone
else was white and she was kind of like
oh am i actually intellectual
or do i just hate the fact that there
are these racist
um stereotypes of black women is
hypersexual
you know is this my real you know
natural orientation
or is it some kind of reaction against
racism and because there weren't that
many black aces it was hard for her to
find someone to discuss this with
so all these issues really compound and
there is i mean
you're touching on the sort of causality
or even the free will
aspects of it i mean is it even a valid
question to ask
do i feel this way because of some
essential notion of who i am versus
uh causal factors that made me this way
like i'm not at all clear that there's
any difference
to be distinguished there i think the
way that i think about it is that it is
good to question
why you might be some way because it
might be that you are this way because
you've been shamed into being um
uncomfortable sexuality and if shame is
what is
you know impeding your life then i think
it's good to work through that and
you know discover sexuality and be happy
i think so i think it's good for
everyone to question
and i also think it's not good when
people become so fixated on asexuality
that it becomes a cause for anxiety
there was one person i interviewed who
said who
though she was asexual liked to um
had a friend with benefits and after
every time
she fooled around this person she would
just be worried and kind of being like
oh
am i am i actually asexual and
am i a bad asexual yeah like my answer
to that would be
you know first of all you can figure
that out on your own but even if you
discovered you weren't asexual that's
fine too
you know like you don't need to be in
this community
for forever it's complicated but i don't
feel like
i don't want identity to become this
really rigid thing where you're afraid
to explore things you might enjoy
because you might discover you're not
asexual so that's one part of it
i think the problem to me isn't that
people questions that the questioning
only goes in one direction you know
the assumption is that you are deluded
if you think you're asexual
and so you need to always be questioning
where
whereas there's almost i'm pretty sure
no questioning
sorry whereas there's very little
questioning of
aloe people whether they might be sexual
so it's the
asymmetry again that bothers me when it
comes to questions of causality
no one is ever shocked when they find
out that someone is allosexual right i
mean that's
that's not not something that is
immediately uh
referred to the dsm for for diagnosis
but um
i mean at the end of the day like we
want to
let people live their lives if they're
not hurting other people right i mean it
doesn't
most most of this advice stems from that
general principle is it is it fair to
say
yes uh absolutely and the so the last
thing i wanted to ask you about
um because this is a different kind of
episode than we usually have on
mindscape the book that you wrote is a
different kind of book than uh most of
my guests have written those who
have written books and and you mentioned
yourself in the book that there were
times that it was hard to write
i mean maybe not you know uh made you
sad but at least like
the level of honesty is a little
demanding you know and and
you're a science writer by training like
was this a different kind of experience
for you and
is this does are there lessons there for
other people who want to talk about
their experiences
it definitely was like we said i'm a
science writer and
though this book is personal in that i
talk about my life and i talk about my
relationships
there was some resistance in some ways
to writing this book because
i what i like to talk about um is
science and technology and biotech i'm
not a very natural
in some ways writer to explore you know
sex and gender
and it was difficult because
it's not just that the self-disclosure
was difficult because i write essays and
so i'm used to self-disclosure
it was the fact that i always wanted to
manage
other people's perception of me and you
know
i talked about this defensiveness you
know i don't want to be seen as
um a killjoy i don't want to be seen as
this really disapproving person
so even as i was writing a book about
why these feelings
um were unfair i felt them anyway in the
process of writing the book
so eventually i think i just had to
realize that
if you're going to write about yourself
in some ways you have to throw yourself
under the bus you have to stop managing
other people's perceptions because
that's going to make you
pose too much and care too much about
looking good and then you're not honest
and then
you know it's be it's pr it's pr for
yourself but it's not useful
so i had to go through some of that in
the revision process
or you can just be a theoretical
physicist and never reveal anything
about yourself in your writing as a
professional
that's that's a much more comfortable
route i found if only that
were available to me well you know there
you go but um
the other thing i guess the thing that i
already said this is the final thing but
this came up while you're just talking i
mean
there aren't that many books about
asexuality and you've written one
and it is a
topic that for the people who are
involved
is very personal and very uh intertwined
with who they are did you feel some sort
of
pressure to get it right and you know be
a good
champion for the people uh that's that's
something i didn't
i don't feel myself when i'm writing
about quantum mechanics or the higgs
boson
i felt enormous pressure there's it's a
double-edged sword because
if there were hundreds of books on
asexual out there
of course it'd be less likely that a new
book would have been gold and published
right
yeah but i think that when you're one of
the first ones and this book is still
one of the first ones
there is as you say that pressure and
that manifests in many ways
so even in the way the book is written
in the topics you know i knew i couldn't
write a book about asexuality
without talking about race not talking
about disability
because there were none out there you
know and it had to in some ways be a
little bit more academic
and more broad and because it had to be
broad and there were you know
these fascinating tangents that i
couldn't talk about and that ended up on
the cutting room floor
and i definitely did feel a sense of
responsibility
to my to the people that i interviewed
i'm critical of parts of the
asexual community writ large in the book
but the people that i spoke to were all
so open and i really worked carefully
with them to make sure
you know i fact checked really carefully
and i was
paranoid about getting everything right
because i don't see this as a gotcha
book you know i'm not revealing
um i'm not proving something bad about
asexuality we're
not there yet you know maybe one day
it'll be a gotcha book by asexuality
but here like i yes i did feel that
pressure um
not necessarily to be a champion because
i think it's okay to be ambivalent
and have questions and to be critical
but to
try to show as diverse a landscape as i
could
well if my experience with the public
discourse is anything to go by i'm sure
people will
hear about your book read it uh
understand what you're saying and
compliment you on your intelligence and
discernment so i i wish you luck
with that process of of recognition
thank you i look forward to that i hope
it's true
i'm sure it'll be true so angela chen
thanks so much for being on the
winescape podcast
thank you again for having me
[Music]
you